لذا فإن السؤال
الحاسم هو أن النظام يقوم بقمع صارم
حتى الآن في الماضي ، وقد عملت هذه الحملات القمعية
بشكل محزن للقول إنه حتى الثوار
الخضر سوف تنجح الحملة هذه المرة
أعتقد أن ما يجب أن نشاهده هو
الانقسامات الداخلية داخل النظام.
أعلم أنني عشت في إيران ، ولا أشك في أن
هناك رغبة في التغيير الأساسي
بين المجتمع حتى لا
أشك ولكن في نجاح الانتفاضات الشعبية ،
فأنت لا تحتاج فقط إلى الضغط من
الأسفل ولكن تحتاج إلى انقسامات في القمة ،
فماذا؟  أنا أنظر إليك تعرف هل
سنبدأ في رؤية انشقاقات داخل النظام
داخل قوات الأمن داخل
الحرس الثوري حتى الآن لم
نر ذلك ، لكن هناك تحذيرًا مثيرًا للاهتمام
الآن وهو الحالة الصحية غير المؤكدة
للمرشد الأعلى آية الله البالغ من العمر 83 عامًا.
وماذا
يفكر فيه الحرس الثوري إذا مات يجب
أن يكون هناك نوع من الانتخابات بين
مجموعة النخبة من الملالي ، هل نعرف من
المحتمل أن يعتقد الناس ذلك
يمكن ترقية الرئيس الحالي إلى
هذا المنصب ، أنا وهو متشدد آخر آخر ،
نعم أعتقد أنه عندما يموت Harmony ،
ما الذي من المحتمل أن يحدث كموقف من نوع Rel Castro ،
فأنت تعرف قائدًا
ضعيفًا يحل محل قائد قوي ومن
ثم تعرف أملي في ذلك  هو أن إيران
تتطور إلى الدنمارك ، لكنني تعلمت
ألا أخلط بين آمالي والتحليل ،
أعتقد أن ما يمكن أن يحدث بعد ذلك
هو في شخصية بوتين الإيرانية ، فأنت تعرف
شخصًا من نظام الأنشيون
من المؤسسة الأمنية أو العسكرية
يطرد القومية الشيعية
واستبدالها بالقومية الإيرانية
مرة أخرى آمل أن أكون مخطئا في ذلك